[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time to see them what is
making the headlines with the columnist
and broadcaster steve richards and the
former conservative special adviser
anita botan great to see both of you
here with us i know till just before
midnight uh front pages then let's start
with the metro leading with figures from
the un suggesting that more than a
million people have fled ukraine in the
last week
the financial times quotes an aide to
the mayor of mariopol who says they're
trying to wipe this city off the face of
the earth
putin vows total victory reports the
times saying the russian president
claims ukrainians have been brainwashed
the guardian writes that president putin
is prompting fears of the worst to come
in ukraine
the eye follows suit with the headline
the worst is yet to come
the telegraph describes those same words
as putin's chilling warning
the daily mail asks who rid the world of
this ranting madman
the son proclaims putin is the extreme
gangster as a father hugs the body of
his dead son
talk to me says vladimir zelinski as
ukraine's president calls for talks with
vladimir putin
and the star has some strong words for
the former chelsea captain john terry
after he tweeted his thanks to departing
club owner roman abramovich
full kit plonker he said
well a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us so let's uh bring in our guest
then steve riches and anita botang um
good to see you both on what is you know
yet another
somber and chilling set of headlines
anita many people quoting the strong
words again today um of the of the
russian president the telegraph included
yes and this has emerged from a
90-minute conversation that president
putin had with the french president
emmanuel macron where he basically said
we're going to go on and on until the
end we won't give up we still consider
ukraine and russia to be one and as as
in one nation that is and as a result um
the the french have advised that they
believe the worst is yet to come and
that's certainly borne out from some of
the images and stories we're hearing of
the attack that took place um today and
certainly
it feels increasingly grim as the days
wear on
yes uh
the attack in the north in chernohev
looks very deadly has to be said with
the latest figures and um very
distressing video online um the guardian
too he will go all the way i mean you
know is the point here that
he's lost everything already in terms of
international reaction he might as well
what what is the suggestion we're
getting from the french president steve
well it's uh it's a suggestion about
putin via the french president who is
keeping this dialogue going and he's
i've read a tweet of his this evening
macro
saying he's going to continue the
dialogue if you reverse the headline and
get something from putin that suggests
he's not going to go all the way
you would think you would be deeply
reassured but think it very odd
clearly from his perspective he regards
victory as total control
and will do anything to get it hence the
headlines about much worse to come
and in a way the west saying or it's not
going to plan well if it doesn't go to
plan he has another plan which is much
worse as he has indicated
to
macron and this raises tons of
nightmarish questions
if sanctions were going to be effective
in the short term i think they would
already have been he would have factored
that in
he thinks he's on a mission
uh clearly indifferent to human life as
he pursues that mission but that he is
on it and won't stop until he succeeds
is basically the theme of quite a few of
the front pages
and the picture in the eye says it all
again again the worst is yet to come and
the problem is
you kind of believe him he's got form
you know you go back to syria you go
back to georgia everyone holds up grozny
and in chechnya devastation to that city
anita so you kind of have to trust him
at his word don't you
um in the sense of his ruthlessness and
in his sense of disregard for human life
i think you can't help but but consider
that
what he says is absolutely what he
intends to inflict on the people of
ukraine and what i think is really
interesting is um the front page of the
the financial times in which um putin
it references um a video conference of
his security council that took place and
in that it's the first time he kind of
addresses the human cost of the war and
essentially talks about the amount that
fallen russian soldiers will receive and
he talks about the fact that he blames
the ukrainian um or all the neo-nazis as
he calls them um that they were using
people as human shields so i certainly
think i mean we have to often read
behind in between the lines of of what
vladimir putin says but that does
suggest some degree of disquiet within
russia about the levels of um you know
of loss of life on the russian and the
ukrainian side and it's very difficult
to ascertain the actual numbers of
people who are losing their lives very
sadly because this as much as this is a
war on the ground it's also a war of
information um and so there's wildly
different claims about the loss of life
but no one can deny the devastation that
vladimir putin is is
wreaking on on ukraine right now yes in
the picture in the financial times uh
does just that does it not a ukrainian
father the paper says weeps for his
teenage son
so just a boy whose body lies on a
stretcher at a hospital in mariopol and
certainly the mayor of that city
suggesting that the shelling
is so intensive that they've not been
out
able to go out to help the injured so
you know extraordinary
difficult painful siege currently
underway there
the male meanwhile
asking who will stop this madman after
the words of the russian foreign
minister today steve sergey lavrov said
you know hawking back to napoleon and
hitler who had the objectives he said to
have europe under their control and now
the americans have europe under their
control and this is a regime that's been
stewing it seems since 1991.
yeah and by the way the images are just
unbearable as they were in syria and
many many other places i'm finding it
very difficult to
to watch some of them as i'm sure
everybody is on that yeah i mean
what what seems to be the case is that
putin was in dresden when the berlin
wall fell he said then it was a
catastrophe the collapse of the soviet
union he would have watched with anger
fury
felt patronized
as that happened and has clearly
convinced himself and this is the kind
of catch-22
that anyone who uh
falls for this have been intoxicated by
the west and therefore our collateral
damage to use that awful term
uh for his mission to re-russify if
that's a term
uh ukraine and some of these other
places and
so when the daily mail poses the
question i've read the rest i've read
the front page they don't answer it
because there is no answer clearly to
that uh question
and the thing about madness is it it
implies that there is no plan that there
is a plan it's awful but there is
clearly as we've already
discussed um but they pose a dramatic
headline or a question in that headline
it's no clear answer
well uh one could be the oligarchs we
will be looking into that what effect if
any could sanctions have on russia's
oligarchs we'll have more on that in
just
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now steve richards
and anita botan we've talked about the
military engagement still underway uh
it's led to as we can see from the metro
a mass exodus
a million already we're told the fastest
mass exodus this century and and no
doubt with more to try to depart steve
to be honest as we were discussing in
the first half these images are so
unbearable
it seems to me that as many as possible
should get out
in the coming days and clearly that's
happening
now this raises huge issues
it's already featured heavily as a sort
of sub theme this week
about the responsibility of european
countries to
take people on such a vast scale
but when you think about what's going to
happen in ukraine you can wholly
understand
why they are trying to get out and you
know quite clearly people have departed
with nothing and there are boxes of
teddy bears for them to pick up so a
child has something to cuddle uh looking
back leaving no doubt dad's
grandfather's uncles behind to fight um
you know very very difficult for all of
those people and they don't know where
they're going next are they many of them
meantime sanctions the squeeze on
russia's rich in the ft
um the seizure of the super yachts i
mean this is something everyone can kind
of
relate to
in a strange way
about you know
can these people get to putin at all
anita
yes and and it feels as though sanctions
are just an important way of showing how
much the kind of west is disapproving of
these individuals rather than that
there's a strong indication that these
oligarchs i mean at this stage where
putin's council and and series of people
that he does at all engage with seems
very very small nevertheless absolutely
critical the the all hard and soft
powers used to inflict maximum damage on
russia at this critical moment and super
yachts um as bizarre as they may seem to
your eyes are a big part of that
yes relate to i meant in terms of their
visible wealth rather than we've all got
a super yacht obviously but there we are
and some fascinating detail in the ft
article about some of them
uh 116
million dollar super yacht uh being held
in the mediterranean port of la ciutat
belonging to igor sechin the boss of
russian oil group rosneft
the other one as well held up in hamburg
wasn't it 600 million dollars 156 meter
dilbar belonging to uh usmanov i mean
it's extraordinary isn't it and the and
it used to be said that uh if if they're
all right he's all right with putin but
uh in ten seconds um they probably won't
do it will it steve
not in in the short term as we've
discussed he's got an objective and he's
going to do everything to it to inverted
commas achieve it but over time it might
and steve when putin is
involved in horrors they haven't been
affected they will be this time